government or its agencies to prevent
the plane from taking off
will the prime minister commit to
informing the house at the earliest
opportunity who was traveling on that
flight yeah why despite being informed
in advance of the flight was no attempt
made by the uk government to keep the
plane on the ground and what will the
prime minister personally do to try and
prevent any similar breaches of
sanctions from happening in the future
i i thank him uh very much i'll make
sure that the uh if so as soon as we can
get some and i don't know the answer to
these questions see if we can get some
information about that mr speaker i'll
make sure the house is properly informed
andy carter yeah thank you very much mr
speaker
earlier this week the planning inspector
waved through a decision by labour
councillors to build a massive logistics
hub in south warrington the plans are
contrary to national policy entirely in
the greenbelt and have been approved
despite more than a thousand letters of
objection
does the prime minister agree with me
that listening to local communities and
protecting our precious green belt must
be at the heart of planning policy and
will he meet with me to see how local
residents can have their voices heard
prime minister
well mr speaker local residents could
have no more powerful voice than uh that
of my uh my honorable friend uh the the
house would have heard him loud and
clear i know the ministry uh department
of leveling up i would have heard him
loud and clear i will make sure that he
gets uh the relevant meeting i'm a
badass
no bullying and no harassment no leaking
no misuse of taxpayers money and no
actual or perceived conflicts of
interest the precious principles of
public life enshrined in this document
must be honored at all time those mr
speaker are the prime minister's own
words from the ministerial code so can
the prime minister tell me on a scale of
one to ten how's he doing with keeping
to those principles
i
we believe we believe uh in this
government uh in adhering to uh the
principles of the ministerial code and
uh and by the way a country and i it's
an important an important point because
mr speaker there's a lot of a lot of
attacks on on mps or on what goes on in
this place and i think it is always
worth stressing that the vast majority
of people who work in the house of
commons members of parliament are are
doing a very good job and working very
hard and are not misbehaving idle
question kevin hollenray
thank you mr speaker um first
convolution has welcomed asylum seekers
from all parts of the world including
syria and the ukraine
but the government's plans just
announced from the 31st of may
to the start of what will be up to 1500
non-detained young single males from
different parts of the world asylum
seekers
in a on a base it will be the center of
a small rural village of 600 people
children
all the way through to elderly residents
that village without streetlights
without police presence
it will devastate the community
it will devastate house prices which
will plummet
and the residents of that village will
not feel safe to leave their homes alone
will my right honourable friend
please on behalf of the community please
stop these plans
prime minister
i i thank you i thank him very much and
uh i can i i know that the uh my right
on friend the home secretary uh is
engaging with him uh and with others
locally about the use of the site and i
would i hear loud and clear what he's
had to say indeed i'm uh
the recipient of many of his
intercessions on this uh on this matter
and i understand the strength of the
strength of feeling uh in his uh in his
constituency and i'm sure that there'll
be further uh meetings between him and
uh and the home office about what we can
do
that ends questions we're gonna let that
out but we're gonna let it clear well
for prime minister's questions as
expected the labour party are going in
quite hard on the cost of living crisis
uh let's bring in our deputy political
editor sam coats joining us live now
from westminster i didn't really manage
to extract a great deal out of the prime
minister though did they
no it wasn't one of those prime
minister's questions that particularly
moved us on uh the prime minister was
under pressure from kirsten to introduce
a windfall tax there was some language
earlier on in those exchanges that
suggested that boris johnson uh was
leaving it open kiestama said you're
going to do a u-turn aren't you boris
johnson did toughen his language his uh
critique of windfall taxes uh later in
his exchanges with kiers dharma but at
no point uh did he uh rule it out uh the
thrust as we were saying beforehand of
this prime minister's questions
inevitably uh going to be
about the cost of living after the nine
percent uh inflation hike uh inflation
figures that we got this morning and the
challenge of the cost of living uh that
as many mps stood up and said uh is
dominating constituents lives at the
moment uh to be honest jake the most
interesting bit of promises questions
was this snp question towards the end uh
where they raised the rather intriguing
subject of a flight on the 26th of
february uh of this year uh which was a
few days after the ban on russian
flights going to the uh
planes going to russia uh and uh boris
johnson was challenged over what exactly
happened when a small estonian private
jet
took off apparently with the
authorisation of transport secretary
grant chat uh something that's
subsequently been uh denied why did a
sanctioned busting plane leave uh uh
inverness airport and head to russia
just after the ban on flight uh went
ahead that was something was put in the
in tray of the prime minister he
promised to find out uh more about it
but expect to hear a bit more about that
rather unusual story being pursued by
the local paper up there the preston
journal but that was probably the most
exciting moment of otherwise uh a
promises questions that we pretty much
prescripted in advance okay sam thanks
very much
well as we've been hearing small
businesses can find it particularly hard
to cope with rising bills already hit by
the pandemic they're now struggling to
stay afloat as prices keep rising and
profits dwindle sky's caterina vitorcy
has been talking to a gym owner in wigan
hello
can you see the duckies
we didn't grow up very well off and i
was very aware growing up that we didn't
have a lot i always didn't want my
children to feel that i never wanted
them to do if i never wanted them to
feel embarrassed because their clothes
they were worrying and stuff so that's i
guess that's what motivates me i can't
let them down got rings swinging into us
daisy
nick priestley has poured everything
into his own gym company
it just made it through covered
lockdowns
he doesn't know if it'll survive what's
coming next
you'll see